[Music]
let's talk about iron man is war machine
coming back you got to be psyched about
you know I hope so uh they we can't this
is another thing we can never talk about
it's like they post people outside of
our homes and if we mention anything
about any Marvel project you know the
you see the red dot Stanley he's got a
right be gonna take you out but you know
it's so funny because I liked it in the
early part of the franchise you just you
wore a military uniform and said be
careful iron man
and then suddenly you get to suit up had
been fantastic yeah except it was really
heavy I mean we talked I think we talked
about this last time and Roberts was not
really heavy Roberts was nice and what
are you talking about light
Robert had to be much lighter than yours
it's racism let's just be honor gets a
very light comfortable suit yes and you
have a very heavy heavy burden
downtrodden II mean what else could it
be
yeah right you're sure this is racist on
that word I'm in the work I'm pretty
sure it was racist yeah
that's that's what you went to right
away when they put you in this thing
well I looked at the label and his said
white light on the inside and mine said
burden yeah you got a really good case
there